because we met you here in LA almost two
years to the date time and this was
before you shot the cosmonaut what
brings you to LA this time around
well a lot of things happen in these two
years basically we got funds made in the
film we shot the film in Latvian Russia
and Spain during 13 weeks it was quite
long time in the film and after that we
spend like a year editing and we are now
in post-production so we almost have the
film finish which is great I'm so happy
about it and I decided to come back for
afm some meetings to you know start
moving the role to to prepare for the
launch of the film that's gonna be in
april 2013 so during the filming did
things go as planned or were there
surprises were you ever in over your
head well there were a lot of surprises
actually we managed to get a co-producer
russian co-producer that a week away
from the shooting when we got everything
prefer all the equipment was sent to
latvia and we got all the the plane
tickets and he chopped out and he went
away with the money so it was like oh
shiettt this is gonna be really hard we
had like that was half the budget to
shoot so instead of like nine or ten
weeks that were going to spend there we
were able to just be there for a month
and that we have get rid of the film at
some point so we made a campaign like a
campaign to save the cosmonaut and we
were asking for forty thousand euros
during a month to at least you know stay
there for two more weeks we write the
screenplay do whatever it takes to be
able to film whatever we could and the
amazing thing is that in three days we
rise 130 thousand euros which was
amazing and we thought that we that was
going to be like the last problem before
the shoot him and then we have a really
really difficult written many many many
things happen really different ones but
we survived and now we have
it was it was it was a car that happy
with the results and how did you raise
the money you so it wasn't through
Kickstarter no no no from the beginning
of the project we we set up like a store
with her mention merchant logic film and
you know pre-sales of the DVD and also
because it was an atheist League on in
Spain we gave people the opportunity to
become investors of the film with a
profit of all what a percentage of the
future profits and that's how we mainly
raise the money during three years and a
half and any new perks with the last
time you had two other incentives to
have any new ones for this campaign we
just made you know the minimum amount to
invest was like a thousand euros and for
this campaign we open that and the
minimum work was a hundred and so we
made a special batch like to save the
cultural edition badge and and after
that we we've been you know when some
perks went out of stock we've made new
ones designs and things like that I'm
going to have new merchandise for when
we release film that's that's when the
crowdfunding is over that's going to be
a few months
you